i don't think it's been clear enough it
is still still a bit confusing things
change all the time so i
generally don't know different
politicians say different things
there is confusion on our high streets
we are being asked
to make yet another lifestyle change
this morning a government minister
tried to explain the new rules if you're
going into pretomange and you are eating
in pretty mango which is some of their
stores you can then obviously you
wouldn't be wearing a face mask because
you're eating
but it's clear good common sense if
you're going in to buy a takeaway and
leaving again
you're treating it like a shop and you
should be wearing a face mask
but the published guidelines still leave
room for interpretation
following days of mixed messages they
came just 12 hours before the law
is enforced in it they said face masks
will be compulsory
in a host of indoor settings including
takeaways
and if you decide to eat or drink
indoors you must keep your mask on
until you sit down shop owners and
managers across the country
are getting prepared if anybody
does not have a mask we will be giving
the money
free to them shamshard runs this
discount store in slough
he's worried about people not following
the new guidelines
there will be certain people who would
be upset about it
and the the most confusing part for us
also as well
is how we can enforce it we can always
encourage people to have it
but god knows how we can enforce it
retailers up and down the country face
the same issue
there will be flash points and we hope
that the police will support
retailers and employees in the right way
in order to deal with consumers who
become overly aggressive or abusive
the new rule won't apply here outside on
the high street
itself but it will in shopping centers
and malls like this one
right across the country and it's down
to police to enforce it
if people don't comply there could be
fines of up to a hundred pounds
believe it man literally well so
everyone has to pay that's a
mandatory from tomorrow otherwise you
get fined fined how much
100 quid that's a lot of money man i
always wear a mask
i work in a care home i have to wear 112
hours
i am protecting people and people need
to know
to get that protection both ways
everybody should wear a mask
for some time now evidence has shown
that covid19 can spread through just
breathing
it's why scientists say this move is
vital
no one wants to see cases go up or to
have to have difficult discussions about
a second lockdown so wearing a face
mask is a really simple way to protect
others and they in turn can protect you
and all it is is a piece of cloth that
blocks any droplets that could be coming
out through speaking or coughing or
sneezing from your nose or your mouth
making sure you're not spreading these
and infecting others and they in turn
are not infecting you
this is now another new way of life a
measure to reduce the spread of the
deadly coronavirus
but how long it will last for or whether
it's part of the new normal
just adds to the list of uncertainty
in rasheed sky news